uh and this is a comment and a statement
that they put out yesterday so no new
one as of today but here it reads it is
our legal responsibility to safely care
for unaccompanied children until they
can be swiftly unified with a parent or
a vetted sponsor as part of the
unification process our office of
refugee resettlement facilitates travel
for the children in its custody to their
family or sponsors across the country in
recent weeks that accompanied children
passed through the westchester airport
and route to their final destination to
be unified with their parents or vetted
sponsor now let's bring in arkansas
republican senator tom cotton senator
welcome
this story is captivating the nation as
we see these flights landing in the dark
of night
why the secrecy and again we have
reached out many times on this report to
the white house and they are not
deploying anybody to us and they have
not given us a direct statement on it so
why the secrecy
well that's a very good question i
remember when i was in the army on
friday afternoon the first sergeant
would brief all the privates uh for the
weekend and he'd remind them that
nothing good usually happens after
midnight and i think we can now extend
that old army wisdom to joe biden's
immigration policy as well the obvious
reason why they're flying these migrants
across the country in the dead of night
is because they don't want to reveal the
consequences of their open borders
policy look if they were proud of their
policy if they thought it was a
political winner for them they'd be
having these flights in the middle of
the daytime they'd be coordinating it
with the local tv stations they'd be
celebrating what they view as a great
accomplishment but they know that joe
biden's open border policy is a
political disaster so they're trying to
hide the consequences of that policy in
the dark of night the new york post
editorial board shared a similar
sentiment and just a heads up we got the
two minute warning from the white house
jen saki about to begin that briefing
shortly we'll go to her when she starts
taking questions because senator she
will likely face questions about this
and our own peter ducey is in that
briefing room here's the editorial board
this morning in addition to their
reporting on this saying quote biden
playing a deadly game using these secret
flights to move migrants there's a
reason the biden administration is using
these secret flights to small airports
to move unaccompanied miners who
illegally cross the border they don't
want voters to know just how many people
are being waived right into the country
because president biden understands that
open borders might be the policy of
progressives but it's not popular among
the majority of americans and bottom
line this is a sign as we see this
happening senator that this is not just
a border issue we are now seeing this
spread to many other parts of the
country and with these flights landing
in westchester
reportedly these migrant children are
being sent
to all over the tri-state area we know
of a facility in long island we have
phone calls into them
they are not returning our calls and
they're certainly not giving us any
statement on the demographic of those
children how they're being vetted
we are told that some landing are men in
their early twenties uh so how big of an
issue is this for president biden
politically if he continues to remain
silent on what his what his strategy is
here well it's very hurtful for
president biden politically but it's a
catastrophe for our country we're going
to be close to 2 million migrants
crossing our border very soon texas is a
big country with a lot of great people
but not even texas can keep two million
new residents there that's why they're
flying them to places like florida and
new york and all points in between and
it's going to put real strain on those
communities on their hospitals on their
school systems on their housing on their
police departments as well all of these
migrants should not be in texas or
florida or new york they should be in
mexico because president biden should
have kept the remaining mexico policy in
place to make sure that people aren't
entering the country with bogus claims
of asylum but he rescinded on his first
day federal courts have told him he has
to re-implement it he's going to do that
next month but in the meantime we've had
two million illegal migrants not just
across the border but fan out across the
country ted cruz tied on this your
republican colleague in the senate
earlier this morning listen
their entire political strategy is based
on secrecy what what is happening at our
southern border is an absolute tragedy
we've had over 1.3 million people cross
illegally we're on a path to have over 2
million people cross and and joe biden
and kamal harris caused this and their
entire strategy
is ignore it and they're counting on the
corrupt corporate media to ignore it as
well so of course they fly in the middle
of the night because they have no
defense
you know and and important to point out
we all sympathize with the fact that
there are children and families that are
willing to make this dangerous journey
and the editorial board of the poor so
eloquently points that out this morning
senator of course there's sympathy for
parents who so desperately have their
children
looking for a better life that they have
a seven-year-old walk to america but by
not having a set policy by not forcing
people to apply for a visa from the
country they live in you're making a
mockery of our immigration laws and the
board goes further to say you are also
encouraging a terrible dangerous
pipeline how many children will be
assaulted or die trying to get here and
that is a really important point to make
senator
it's vitally important
i don't see how it's moral to encourage
desperate parents who are living in
poverty to try to send their children
thousands of miles across latin america
to get to our southern border it's also
totally arbitrary there are many places
in africa and asia and europe that would
love to come here but simply because
they don't share a land border with the
united states or can't get to a land
border they're not welcome in our
country this is the moral catastrophe of
joe biden's immigration policy they act
like it's some great moral victory when
in reality it's creating incentives for
very dangerous and immoral behavior and
luck
people just want some transparency on
this issue we'll see what the white
house says in just a moment mike pompeo
putting out earlier it's simple we
should know who is coming in and out of
our country and senator marsha blackburn
by the way is dealing with this in
tennessee as well she says the
administration's been secretly flying
illegal aliens into tennessee for months
and now we know that they're doing the
same in new york uh so you and many
other members of congress are
identifying that this is not just a new
problem this is something that's been
going on for some time now we have
pictures showing it there in westchester
senator thank you
thank you